the laughs from this cast certainly
didn't stop with Emma Watson in one
interview alongside Daniel Radcliffe
Emma Watson and rert Grint who played
Ron Weasley talk about just how
difficult it was for them to kiss on
screen thanks to their sibling-like
relationship in real life I just
remember your face getting closer and
closer to every time you talk about this
you make it sound like an actual horror
show it wasn't that bad I know and from
the sound of it this moment was just as
funny when it was really happening on
set everyone wants to be on set CU
everyone was like this is going to be
good clearly this cast tends to be an
open book in interviews there was one
moment though when Daniel Radcliffe
refused to share a certain detail and it
was all thanks to a not safe for work
present from rert Grint on the Jonathan
Ross show Radcliffe explained that
Rupert Grint once gifted him a trumpet
that he himself engraved what did he
engrave on it could you tell us was it
too personal I no I think it was just
abuse